pensez-vous que les Parisiens prennent le
changement climatique au sérieux je pense que c'est 50
50. donc je suis l'un des finalistes et
lauréat du vrai prix pour Kenai
bonjour à tous je suis journaliste scientifique
et créateur de la chaîne YouTube
et  comme vous l'avez peut-être deviné à mon
accent, je suis français,
nous sommes ici aujourd'hui en plein cœur de
Paris pour découvrir le pouvoir de l'innovation
et trouver des solutions au changement climatique,
étape par étape, le
changement climatique est l'un des
défis les plus urgents  nous sommes confrontés aujourd'hui, mais nous
pensons que l'optimisme en action peut faire
la différence.
Nous allons changer maintenant lors d'événements
qui ne se déroulent pas à Las Vegas comme nous
aurions pu le penser, mais à Paris, où les
esprits les meilleurs et les plus brillants se
réunissent pour créer  des choses arrivent,
nous rencontrerons certains des incroyables
finalistes de Earth Sharp qui sont ici pour
partager leurs propres initiatives inspirantes.
Notre mission principale est de restaurer ce que nous
appelons la forêt oubliée d'algues. Nous
utilisons du métal recyclé pour fabriquer des
coutumes améliorées.
Commençons par  rues de Paris et
entendre ses charmants habitants ce qu'ils
pensent de la crise climatique
[Musique]
pensez-vous que les Parisiens prennent le
changement climatique au sérieux je pense que c'est 50
50. pourquoi, comme les gens qui le prennent
au sérieux, ce sont des gens de mon âge si proches  18
à 25 ans mais les seniors, je ne pense pas qu'ils
soient intéressés, ils s'en
moquent parce qu'ils ne seront plus
là à l'avenir et cela n'aura d'
impact que sur nous qui, selon vous, sommes les plus
responsables de la réparation  la
crise climatique je pense que ça vient des
gens en fait nous sommes tous dans le même
bateau ça vient de la politique ça vient
des entreprises ça vient des citoyens
le changement sera efficace si tout
cela ensemble agit pour limiter
au maximum le changement climatique pour moi
les gens puissants pour changer, ce sont évidemment les
gouvernements et les grandes entreprises, mais
nous devons tous travailler ensemble en tant que
citoyens, nous devons faire pression pour que
la façon dont nous consommons les choses soit différente va
faire en sorte que la coopération produise différemment
[Musique]
maintenant revenons à  changez maintenant et
rencontrez nos finalistes nous allons rencontrer Yan
de c4rester et Charlotte pour makuru
je m'appelle Ian fabik je suis le
responsable scientifique de Sea forest et de Sea Forest
la chose principale notre mission principale est de
restaurer ce que nous appelons les Oubliés  La
technique de la forêt d'algues dans le gravier vert océan a été initialement développée
par nos partenaires scientifiques en Norvège. Vous
avez juste une pierre très normale, vous voyez
qu'avec des épices d'algues, vous les cultivez
dans des conditions adéquates et
vous pouvez ensuite les déployer simplement dans la mer à partir d'
un  les bateaux continuent de croître, ils
s'attachent au fond marin, créent une nouvelle
forêt d'algues et, espérons-le,
attirent à nouveau la biodiversité dans
ces zones avant que
la principale réussite que nous ayons eue lors de nos
essais de recherche initialement au Portugal ait
déclaré que nous avions une preuve de concept.  que
la technique fonctionne définitivement, mais maintenant
nous avons à nouveau obtenu beaucoup de soutien de la part de la
municipalité de Kaskarish qui est
avec nous depuis le début.
Nous avons également de plus grandes entreprises maintenant
qui commencent à nous financer parce
qu'elles comprennent que c'est principalement
dans l'océan.  cela signifie plus de poisson, cela
signifie plus de ressources que ces
sociétés utilisent réellement, donc il y a
un élan en ce moment pour nous
de croître et d'obtenir de la visibilité et des partenaires
[Musique]
je m'appelle Charlotte, je viens de Nairobi, au
Kenya, je suis la fondatrice  de poêles propres mukuru
et ce que nous faisons, c'est utiliser du
métal recyclé pour fabriquer des sous-verres améliorés,
puis nous nous associons à des femmes
propriétaires d'entreprises locales pour les distribuer
au dernier homme, donc je fais partie de la belle liste
et je suis gagnant du prix réel pour
Kenai, félicitations, merci, l'
un des impacts positifs les plus significatifs
du gourou au sein de ces
communautés est qu'il réduit le logement
jusqu'à 90 % lorsque vous utilisez le bon carburant, cela
réduit les coûts de consommation de carburant jusqu'à
60 % et ainsi les familles peuvent
faire des économies.  de deux dollars chaque
semaine lorsqu'ils utilisent nos magasins,
donc dans les années à venir, dans les
cinq à sept prochaines années, nous voulons atteindre 10
millions de foyers avec nos
poêles mukuru, mais nous avons également une nouvelle
briquette antipaludique en instance de brevet,
euh, qui est  toujours en cours mais nous espérons
distribuer cela dans 10 millions de
foyers, ainsi que dans les magasins
au cours des 10 prochaines années.
[Music]
change now est une plate-forme qui met en valeur
le pouvoir de l'innovation scientifique dans
l'élaboration de solutions durables,
c'est incroyable d'en être témoin  les
initiatives et
technologies révolutionnaires présentées ici et en
particulier par nos finalistes,
mais cela ne s'arrête pas là, nous voulons
vous donner des conseils pratiques et
des changements de style de vie que vous pouvez
intégrer dans votre vie quotidienne
pour un avenir plus durable, de la
réduction des déchets plastiques à
la conservation.
ensemble, nous pouvons faire la
différence, agissons et créons
un monde meilleur,
merci de nous avoir rejoint dans ce
voyage passionnant à travers Paris,
n'oubliez pas d'aimer, de vous abonner et de partager cet
épisode pour sensibiliser au
changement climatique et inspirer les autres.  pour agir
ensemble, nous pouvons être le changement que nous voulons
voir dans le monde
[Musique]
étrangère